[Music]
in this post endgame well the Thor
series is breaking new ground for Marvel
as Yoda in some becomes a first hero to
be granted for solo films thanks to a
ton of new details spewing from the hype
factory that San Diego comic-con
we know a little more about what to
expect from the upcoming Thor for if
you're a little behind on your Thor law
let's get you up to speed in 2017 under
the direction of Tiger ytt Ragnarok
sprung into theaters the movie
chronicled Thor's attempts to save a
scar from his conniving and powerful
sister hella along with a struggle to
escape from the garbage planet sakaar
with Loki and Bruce Banner by
introducing new characters like Valkyrie
along with everybody's favorite alien
Bros called and meek amen I'm cool this
is me we're gonna jump on their
spaceship and get out of here
want to come and injecting a much needed
dose of whimsy into the fall series
Ragnarok became a welcome addition to
the MCU receiving rave reviews and
crushing the box-office
Ragnarok finds so learning to accept us
as Odin and Heimdall said that God is
not a bush there are people recognizing
that the only way to save his home
Isleta it be destroyed he finally takes
his place as king as he Shepherds his
citizens into space charting a course
for a new home on earth
tragically thus where Thanos comes in
leaving half of the Asgardian refugees
dead in his quest for the Infinity
stones as Avengers infinity war begins a
devastated Thor survives Santos's final
snap leaving him to spend endgame
seeking justice and revenge for those
he's lost when Thanos is at last
defeated Thoris the only one of the
original Avengers left standing
ultimately he ends up joining the
guardians of the galaxy to fight evil
throughout the universe leaving his
right-hand woman Valkyrie in charge of
the recently founded Norwegian territory
of newest guard all of this has set the
stage for what's to come in the next
storm movie after the success of Thor
Ragnarok it makes sense a Marvel would
want director Taika Waititi to return
for Thor for considering the acclaim
that whitey T's irreverence and dry
comedic sensibilities garnered for
Ragnarok by taking one of Marvel's most
serious and austere superheroes and
making him and his surrounding cast
totally accessible and even fun ytt
immediately left a mark on the franchise
and made himself indispensable as a
fresh voice in the MCU transformed
into a snake and he knows that I love
snakes so I went to pick up the snake to
admire it and he transformed it back
into himself for he was like yeah it's
me
even though Marvel fans are likely
thrilled that ytt is officially
confirmed to return for the 4th for film
it does get in the way of one of his
other long-awaited projects ytt is
placing his adaptation of the cyberpunk
anime classic Akira on hold so that he
can return to the MCU despite the fact
that the project had recently been
fast-tracked by Warner Brothers fans can
only hope that ytt will be able to
revive Akira after he completes Thor 4
but it's still clear that the filmmaker
is giving up plenty of opportunities to
make sure he can return to the Marvel
cosmos it's usually a safe bet that
Marvel will have a strong showing a San
Diego comic-con and in 2019 as a studio
look toward post phase 3 there was
plenty of breaking news about upcoming
Marvel projects including force next out
saying during the huge Marvel panel on
Saturday July 20th a SDCC cast members
along with whitey T himself made an
appearance to make a few major
announcements about Thor 4 first after
film's official title will be Thor love
and thunder which could give us some
indication about the film's tone as well
as tell us a little about what lies in
store for Thor himself maybe the hero
will be able to find a little time for
romance between fights with the various
bad guys as far as a release date goes
Thor love and thunder will hit theaters
on November 5th 2021 serving as a finale
of the MC use phase for a 4/4 movie
likely wouldn't have even gotten a green
light if Chris Hemsworth hadn't hopped
back on board to play what has now
become his signature role so it's not
surprising that he is expected to return
as a god of thunder though Hemsworth
store was a bit too serious in the
earlier films Ragnarok an endgame both
saw a silly aside of the superhero in
Ragnarok during his time as a captive of
Jeff Goldblum's ridiculous Grand Master
he ends up slated to fight the Hulk
leading to one of the film's most
infamous lines even as he tries to save
his ancestral home from Helles clutches
he maintains a healthy sense of humor
and game sees thaw returning to his
serious roots as he Monza victims of
Sano's but he still gets plenty of
comedic moments when his fellow Avengers
discover broth or five years after the
team part sways
give me that serving has an unexpectedly
comedic presence in such a happy film
Hemsworth anchors his emotional beats
while still keeping his performance
light and entertaining proving that he's
more than capable of playing four in
love and thunder and for years to come
[Music]
quite a few familiar faces were returned
for Thor love and thunder including one
Oscar winner who's been absent from the
film series for a while now in an
unsurprising bit of news that was also
announced at SDCC Tessa Thompson will
return to play the fierce swaggering
Valkyrie who's currently handling
matters and newest guard during Thor's
post endgame Jones with the guardians of
the galaxy Thompson and Ted Marvel
honcho Kevin Feige also made it clear
that the movie would confirm valkyries
bisexuality noting that she needs to
find her queen making for a landmark in
representation and diversity in this
multi franchise universe however the
most exciting casting announcement was
undoubtedly that Natalie Portman who
paid Thor's love interest Jane in both
Thor and Thor the dark world will return
to the franchise and pickup me all near
herself as a new Thor just as the
character did in a recent comics run
from writer Jason Aaron as Portman took
the stage and held me all near high to
celebrate the swilling development she
quipped quotes I've always had a little
hammer Envy the talented actress has
returned to the world of Thor would have
been big enough news that letting
Portman become a superhero in her own
right just ups the ante check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]